this is the direction that I can film
behind the camera I can't film because
there's military stuff but if I go over
here then you can see the soldiers that
are with us I feel very safe pretty guys
it is a second full day in Seoul and
today is really exciting because we're
going to DMZ the demilitarized zone
which is pretty much we we get to look
into North Korea
that's pretty cool I actually woke up
with my throat being a little bit worse
than yesterday so bear with me
mmm so frustrating the whole group is
gathered and we're about to take off
baby we're going to North Korea today
really you know that is North Korea
[Music]
they're known to do some have you heard
about North Korean nuclear war oh really
of money that you saw me yeah would you
see that that's the first my goodness
[Music]
rights are currently taking the DMZ
spite or so back in the sixties there
were 31 North Korean spies that snuck
into South Korea and they were trying to
kill the president so right now we're
looking at these statues of two
policemen who are very crucial in trying
to prevent the spies from killing the
president and we're learning a lot about
the separation of North and South Korea
so right behind me that's North Korea
maybe that's North Korea right over
there it's the first time a far swim
that's what you said people in that
country way over there they can't come
over here yeah yeah it's sad a lot of
families got split up I was sucked in
fourteen went a little one I know that's
a lot of families that actually happened
to a lot of people it's like you go to
like say a different city away from home
oh there's some really weird bugs here
by way of flying around to North Korean
bugs
[Music]
yeah North Koreans no no man walking
around the streets or anything I hear a
North Korean bird alright let's see if
this works
there are people currently farming and I
can see them with my own eyeballs let's
see if the camera could get it there we
go hey this is the DMZ spite or in our
spies and then in tintin tintin turn it
did it did it I love how we can see
North Korea right over there but then
it's like we got a remind y'all this
side of South Korea we got some banana
flavor to milk this is gonna be
interesting
it sounds pretty good it looks pretty
good let's see it's good there's no
banana in yours just the banana flavor
oh we gotta get this to the state I
think what do you think about it really
well you already finished it you're
saying in past tense
oh all right so we're enjoying some
Korean snacks which is very interesting
because I have only ever experience
eating Japanese snacks because of JK
they love Japanese everything so Julia
always buy Japanese snacks for the
office and now I'm getting to experience
it's Korean snacks and these are
actually just as good it's not in my
opinion little bit better than feminine
sex because they're also really soft
they're not that sweet and there's a lot
of variety and the flavors are really
good to me because that's the reason why
we love Japanese snacks because you
could really taste the actual flavor of
the thing that you're eating so like if
it's strawberry it's really strawberry
and I just had some like little
strawberry cake and it was really good
it's really really patient custard
[Music]
Twinkie but better just to sweet Emal's
it's our good try this movie what makes
it better than the legato yeah
[Music]
banana milk alright so we've just
crossed a like Border Patrol kind of
thing into the seams the area they took
our passports and technically not
supposed to be filming right now we're
in the car no one's looking
but that field right there it's a land
mine field so they're like don't get out
of the car all right
hurry men this is a direction that I can
film behind the camera I can't film
because there's military stuff but if I
go over here then you can see the
soldiers that are with us it's not very
safe it's really interesting
everything's very serious oh I forgot to
mention to yesterday they prepped us and
said that we have a dress code we
couldn't be wearing any ripped jeans we
had to be wearing closed-toe shoes
nothing too revealing and if there had
to be like a t-shirt so they're saying
that only the UN are allowed to take any
photos or videos of the demilitarized
zone
what do you ladies know the United
Nations delegate no the United Nations
it's like an organization where
different countries of the world get
together and make decisions it's like
the world government pretty much sort of
I'm part of the United Nations not
really all right we get to take some
photos with the soldiers who are
protecting us from the flag DMZ right
behind this
where we can't take photos or video so
that's it
it's a thing a lot of them you go see
the DMZ or in a bunker that's awesome
you wouldn't afraid about Jupiter oh
nice how does it feel to be in a bunker
good good I'll keep you safe uniform is
really very educational too because then
we get to learn a lot about the history
of why there's even the DMZ to begin
with so now we're visiting the fence
where those 31 North Korean spies crust
so these are some statutes showing what
they were wearing what they look like
how they cross and people what they do
here is they write messages on ribbon
and then they tie it to the tent
kind of like giving some sort of wish or
you know whatever message you would want
to write so this is what I wrote wishing
for peace and unification for Korea
exclamation mark part tip this is what
k0 peace and prosperity to Korea and all
humankind
this is a road hogwards forever
you're so cute baby whoa look at that go
there on the ground yeah that's how they
snuck in and they were heading to get
the president at the blue house isn't it
interesting how they call their
president tells the blue house and back
in the US at the White House
[Music]
so this is everyone's ribbon other
messages because she agreed again
[Music]
the wind that knows you're placing a new
message of positivity on ffense
as welcoming your your positivity
[Music]
please I think you wanna do yours little
baby
I'm between us look cute I'll go
inscribe all right so it's lunchtime and
we are in a very familiar setting it's
some Korean barbeque but apparently
we're having duck this time so we're
used to pork and beef
we're gonna have some duck today
[Music]
[Music]
alright guys we are now at peace Park
you see those statues right behind it so
they're heading to the north
so all these pinwheels behind me - it's
kind of a symbol of peace and unity is
like a wind coming from the north in the
south like you know wind it is not
divided and so this whole like there's a
lot of artwork and a lot of symbolism
everywhere it's really beautiful
[Music]
[Applause]
are you trying to do
[Applause]
[Music]
like the Korean barbecue baby yeah but
that's dirty and barbecue greed the
crazy part about coming to Korea though
is that we're not like there's no real
like big culture shock with the food
because in k-town in LA we have just
about everything it's like the biggest
k-town and outside of Korea
yeah so even an email on it like locals
here telling us like that had been
decayed like there's not a whole lot you
can't get in k-town in LA yeah they're
saying that a lot of the Korean stuff is
in k-town yeah we're not gonna be far
from Seoul when we go back home I really
never knew so much about Korean history
until now which is later true it's like
obviously you're gonna learn if you're
here but I'm just really shocked at how
like little line you like I don't really
I don't even know if there was a Korean
War until a few years ago like that's
all okay just I did not even know that
that was a thing all right we're ending
the day at a temple we're gonna have
dinner here we're gonna eat some mud I'm
food monk food sounds funny
yeah and so we're gonna see what that's
all like all right now I'm gonna try a
temple
there's nothing like almost like barley
flavored water you feel more Buddhist or
president warned them now you try to be
as strong as possible to describe this
to you right yeah kimchi soup yeah
thanks super spicy - not a big fan of it
not a big family
it's like a grape plum tomatoes great
plum tomato
rum toe you know we're at a Michelin
star recommended restaurant here I
didn't realize that
really
so this is like fancy meditation
[Music]
what do you think on the wall over there
says pre-meal I am ashamed to be eating
you get rid of greed in my mind Google
and to keeps my physical being in order
to achieve enlightenment third course
[Music]
dumplings Michelin dumplings
how is that very much area you can taste
it
no meat it's different
miss me
[Music]
this is so cute that you won't eat it
will definitely eat it because it looks
like you put on your face for a facial
AIESEC we totally under we totally
underestimated a vegetarian Michelin
reviewed yeah I think then we're gonna
get forward a space it out really well
and then they also trick you people to
use with really small dishes and like
everyone is right deception all right so
we finished having dinner the month
dinner it was very interesting a lot of
flavors I've never had before it was
very light and flavorful and I got it
surprisingly very full so we need about
it's like three times right
break up good job baby
you're so cultured let me bow see
[Applause]
we came to check out the temple at night
it's really beautiful look at all these
lantern
okay you gotta respect this this is a
temple yeah religious gotta be
respectful baby oh my god dizzy oh they
have lanterns that are green to match my
hair as it's faded
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I live I love this family I love this
family too
[Music]
[Music]